[Applause]
mark Philip II is an American Strongest
Man winner how does a 300-pound man move
an object nearly eighty five times his
weight behind me as a twenty six
thousand pound truck that we're gonna
hook mark up to and see how far he can
walk with it David Sandler is a Sports
physiologist and president of strength
Pro a consulting firm for athletes to
determine how mark pulls the truck
Sandler fits him with a battery of
biomedical sensors we're gonna measure
his muscle activity we're going to
measure his breath by breath ventilation
rate and we're gonna measure his heart
rate the data will reveal how demanding
the truck pool is on Mark's body
assisting David is Alan Macy
an engineer with bio back a company that
specializes in medical data acquisition
to determine how much pulling force mark
generates to move the truck the team
also brings in Tom Co zeal Tom works
with transducer techniques specialists
in the design of industrial load cells
we have hooked up to the front of the
truck that the strongman is gonna pull
the load cell will measure Mark's
pulling power in pounds of force the
biomedical data is synchronized to the
load cell the team can compare each of
mark's muscle movements to the load cell
data revealing not just how hard he
pulls but when and with which muscles
we've never analyzed anything like this
before
I expect heavy breathing and a very high
heart rate minute-by-minute
this is probably the most demanding
activity in all of sport
Oh
there it is
mark pulled the truck 120 feet and he
did it in just 28 seconds the key to
this superhuman feat lies at the
intersection of geometry and physics a
technology called motion capture reveals
how
like a sprinter in the blocks mark leans
forward at an angle of approximately 45
degrees to drive the greatest force down
the leg and into the ground a higher
angle and he would generate less force
on the line a lower angle and his feet
couldn't maintain enough traction here's
the surprise mark doesn't perform one
sustained pull he pulls the truck in
repetitions
despite the trucks 13 ton weight it
takes only 500 pounds of force to get it
rolling
after each pull the line slackened and
the force drops close to 100 pounds
because the truck is so heavy friction
slows it almost immediately as the force
drops mark must then pull again to keep
it rolling
driving the force back up to nearly 500
pounds this on-off cycle continues
during the entire pull up to 500 pounds
and back down again
and again it's like doing a quarter ton
squat not once but 48 times in less than
30 seconds
but that's not all the biomedical data
reveals its own surprise despite the
enormous muscular strain marks breathing
remained steady similar to a marathon
runner marks breathing about once every
second but breathing pretty shallowly
like a leader in each time and so that
and that's very regular during the
course of the entire mark paced himself
through the pull his breathing and heart
rate all remained paced and regular
pulling a truck may seem like a feat of
strength but it's really a feat of
strength endurance